connecting cops with the community that
was the goal of several events tonight
in las vegas for national night out but
there was also really an emphasis on
crime prevention orc omana has more on
how police plan to take action
this year metro police also wanted to
use the event to combat the rising crime
across las vegas
families food and free entertainment
filled bob price park in northeast las
vegas as part of national night out it
was actually pretty fun the valley-wide
get-together is meant to help the
community connect with cops it's fun
to meet
some of the
[Music]
police officers the kids can get more
comfortable letting them know that
police are great people they're there
for us the latest numbers from metro
show homicides in las vegas are up 67
percent compared to this time last year
with more murders in nine of the 10 area
commands including the northeast
definitely is concerning metro police
hope events like national night out will
help combat these crimes it's a
disturbing trend that we've seen but by
coming together we can have a positive
impact on those crimes
knowing where they're occurring
partnering with our business
stakeholders i asked why there's been
such an increase really haven't been
able to put our finger on to it right
now
the most important part is that we've
recognized it now the next step is to
take action get out and build that
just having kind of a stronger community
and base
just takes away crime as well many are
happy knowing police are here to help it
makes me feel safe metro says they'll
continue to connect with the community
at their first tuesday events reporting
in the northeast valley orca mana live
local now